Speaker 1: A new report from CNN at least five
former Trump White House staffers are talking to
the House Jan. six committee. This is a report
from CNN's Kaitlan Collins filed yesterday,
and it contains some very interesting reports. At
least five former Trump administration staffers
have voluntarily spoken with the House Committee
investigating the Jan. six attack on the Capitol.
Now, voluntarily has a lot wrapped up in it.
Some are interpreting voluntarily to mean
these are Trump staffers who have turned who
are. It has weighed on their conscience what
they know. And so they came forward and said,
I want to speak. That is not what voluntarily
necessarily means. Voluntarily means they weren't
subpoenaed. That that's all that we can say for
sure voluntarily means. And so it may have been
that these individuals had no real interest in
speaking out about what happened, but they they
received a request to speak to the committee
and their lawyers said, or it was implied or
it became understood that you can decline this,
but then you're going to get a subpoena. And
a lot of people don't want to get a subpoena,
so we can't really read too much into voluntarily.
OK? Those discussions come as lawyers working for
the committee have also reached out to
a range of other Trump aides to inquire
whether they would be interested in speaking with
the committee voluntarily without the threat of a
subpoena. So there it is. The five former staffers
who have had conversations with the committee
have done so with either members or their staff.
Some believe they have information worth sharing,
while others are hoping to avoid being legally
compelled to talk to the committee. Very exactly
what we're talking about. Congressman Jamie
Raskin, who's on the committee? He's a Democrat.
He said on CNN yesterday quote, I've got
good reason to believe a number of them
are horrified and scandalized by what took
place on January 6th, and they want to do
their legal duty and civic duty by coming
forward to explain exactly what happened.
We don't know that to be true. That's Jamie Raskin
claiming that we're going to continue to encourage
everybody who has relevant information to come and
talk. The engagement could provide insight for the
committee that's seeking to learn more about the
actions of former President Trump and supporters,
according to five former Trump aides. Counsel for
the committee has emailed or texted them directly
to ask whether they are interested in coming
to talk to the congressional investigators,
often looking for context on what happened inside
the West Wing before the insurrection on January
6th. Several people have voluntarily sat down with
the committee. Others have declined the requests
or not responded. The outrage has ranged from
junior level staffers to more seasoned officials.
The outrage is the outreach is not necessarily
necessarily because the committee believes
staffers were involved in what happened, but
they want to glean context on what took place.
Period. So one of the real questions here,
and unfortunately, you know, I still believe
and I know it upsets many of you. I don't think
there's going to be real consequences for people,
regardless of what the answer here is. But one of
the questions that we continue to seek to answer
is to what degree was Trump involved in planning?
To what degree did Donald Trump know that it was
going to get violent? To what degree did Donald
Trump encourage or want exactly what happened to
happen? We have a variety of reasons to believe,
including the fact that Trump spoke so positively
about the rioters, even as the riot was going on
on January 6th in that recorded video statement
that was released. We have every reason to believe
that he was involved and he was enjoying it until
or other than the fact that, as he said, the
protesters, the rioters, the insurrectionists
looked low class, which he felt was making him
look bad. So the broader context is momentum is
building in terms of the committee. We don't
know whether people speaking to the committee
are really turning on Trump. But I still don't
think this is going to lead to the types of
consequences you and I would like to see. I know
it upsets many of you. I know there are people in
the audience who when I say this, they write to me
and say, David, you're part of the problem. Saying
there won't be consequences is likely to make
that happen. It's a self-fulfilling prophecy.
I reject that completely. What I say will have
no bearing on whether there are consequences.
There are going to be no real consequences for
the top people. So we're talking about Trump.
We're talking about Mark Meadows. We're talking
about members of Congress like Mo Brooks, Lauren
Boebert, Marjorie Taylor Greene, Louie Gohmert,
etc. There may be, you know, a sort of mild public
shaming of some kind. Republicans will, of course,
claim it's all bogus, that none of it is deserved,
that it's all a witch hunt. There will be slaps on
the wrist for most of the actual insurrectionists.
Remember this 300 to 400 of these cases that
are now pending. There will be some slaps on the
wrist. Some people will get slightly more serious
sentences. We've seen a couple of them handed out
few years ago. Trump's political career may just
kind of peter out, or he'll end up president
again, which is really scary. And at the end of
the day, this is not going to so damage Trump
that the potential to be president again will be
eliminated. It may does not happen. It may deflate
Trump if this gets really bad. If what we learn
is really damaging. It may deflate Trump. It may
hurt Republicans in 2022, which itself functions
to discourage Donald Trump from running in 2024.
I hope I'm wrong. I hope that there are real
consequences and that they are significant, et
cetera. But it is certainly not. Seeming
likely to me at this point in time,
if you know now here's who I want to hear from. If
you just want to say, David, stop repeating that.
Skip it, don't e-mail me. I get those emails all
the time. If you want to explain to me the actual
path for how it will happen and who will hold, the
members of Congress allegedly involved accountable
White House staff allegedly involved accountable
Trump accountable. Explain to me the sequence
of events and how it will happen. I don't see it.
But if you understand the path forward on that,
I do want to hear from you. You can
email info at David Pakman dot com.